matt patricia became coach of the lions
in 2018 brian flores without even being
defensive coordinator became head coach
of the miami dolphins after one year
greg ciano had stepped into that spot
and he didn't step into it for very long
the statement came out yesterday
afternoon i've informed mr kraft coach
belichick that i'm stepping down from my
position at the patriots this is not the
result of any one event but rather a
realization that i need to spend more
time on my faith in family i don't want
to look back years from now and wish i
had done things differently therefore
i'm taking time away from the game to
recalibrate my priorities hey big cat
this is a loaded statement and i don't
like
to speculate on what in the hell is
going on and what caused this to happen
but
it it inv it cries out for speculation
when you put in there this is not the
result of any one event how does not the
average human react to that by saying
well maybe it's two events maybe it's
three what what events triggered this
what did you do greg schiano that forced
you to walk away from this job when you
put that in the statement you are
inviting people to come to that
conclusion or at least wonder what in
the hell is going on behind the curtain
here
no this is obviously a statement that
leaves a lot out there for people to
speculate for people to think what's
going on
you know i i probably it's probably like
you said multiple events probably
something family related but it also
might be hey i don't want to work uh for
the patriots because you know you're
chris sims has always said it's a hard
place to work it's a hard place to be
you know to grind it out every day
the reward is a super bowl ring most
likely at the end of at the end of the
year but it's not for everyone and maybe
greg shiano had that moment where he
said this isn't for me i'm just excited
because this might mean brett bielema
defensive coordinator i need brett
bielma back on the sidelines i need to
watch brett bielma go up and down i need
to see bill belichick yell at brett
bielma but here's the thing it's one
thing for chris sims to realize as he's
breaking into coaching that he doesn't
want to devote that kind of time
commitment to the game shiano's been
coaching for 30 years and even if he
doesn't already have that work ethic
surely he has gleaned at some point in
talking to people he knows over the last
three decades that bill belichick does
things a certain way and you're going to
be chained to a desk and you're going to
be busting your ass and you're not going
to see your family so the idea that he's
just getting the realization now before
they even have a single offseason
session with players that it's going to
be too much work for him that that
how in the hell do you not already know
that before you tell bill belichick i'll
come to work for you
i don't know people change people's you
know opinions change there also might be
an element where and again this is all
speculation we're just throwing stuff
against the wall because he left
everything so ambiguous but there might
be also an element where you know going
from college to the nfl he probably
might have said you know what i like
being in college more which is a rare
thing you know most guys the nfl is the
dream job but he's been in college for a
while obviously the bucks thing we all
watch but he's been at ohio state and he
was rumored for the tennessee job the
head coaching job so maybe that was part
of the deal too maybe it was uh hey
listen if you're here you're here for
the next three years you don't get
another head coaching job you don't get
to climb the ladder i don't know there's
a million different things that could
have happened it's weird it's it's very
vague we can speculate i i honestly it's
it's it feels weird to speculate because
it you just don't know what's going on
but that he left it wide open with that
statement
oh there's so much in there that you
could speculate about and just keep it
simple if you don't want people to
speculate but even then they'll still
speculate there's always going to be
speculation when there's an abrupt
resignation like this and he just threw
more logs onto the fire with every word
of that statement by the way
when to hear you say people change i
mean that is spoken like a guy who's
having a kid in late june yeah that is
that is a guy who is becoming a dad you
have changed in a good way for the most
part i've been i've been rooting for
this for a while and i'm glad to see it
happen hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports